Let's briefly talk about Unreal Engine
as it applies to game development.
Unreal Engine has always fundamentally been a game
engine, allows you to create content,
let players move around and interact with it,
and ultimately allow this dynamic exchange between what
the player wants to do and an experience
that you create for them.
There are many benefits to using Unreal Engine for game
development.
But as it pertains to Sequencer,
the most important thing to remember
is that we are building this world for the players
to interact with, and then occasionally stepping
in to present them with a visual experience
or a montage of images, sound, et cetera.
And we do that predominantly through Sequencer.
One of the important things that we
want to discuss as we go throughout this course
is the concept of how games are made, released,
and content patched into it.
So throughout this process of building our sequence,
you'll find that we will do certain practices
to keep good organization and structure, keeping in mind
that typically during a video game,
you're going to have several cinematic experiences, meaning
you want to have a very strong, flexible,
and adaptable pipeline and process
for building your sequences and running them or executing
them in the final game.